plans are plans i'm a badass not an
anarchist
all right everyone's here today we're
going to work on our courtroom demeanor
pass the seminar is not optional diaz
you're testifying in an aggravated
assault case tomorrow
the d.a is worried about how you present
yourself on the stand why
i'm fine on the stand look i'll make
this real simple so even these dumb
dumbs can understand
man did crime i'm sorry can you make her
stop
doing that weird thing with her face
crying
and when this is over i'm gonna find you
and i'm gonna
break those little fingers miss diaz
please stop threatening the stenographer
this is an important case you need to do
well
fine i'll take your dumb ass seminar
that's the spirit
diaz you did it they found them guilty
on all charges
huh wells advice worked
so where's your happy place i'm in a
cabin
in the middle of nowhere inside it's
just me and that
stupid slimy defense attorney and i'm
beating the hell out of him
i break a dining room table over his
head then i rip off his arm
and shove it where the sun don't shine
then i reach down his throat
and shake his hand
yeah okay i'm going to go ahead and
schedule you for a psyche valve
the dinner with my parents on saturday
is to introduce them to marcus
what why didn't you just tell me i
didn't know stuff was getting that
serious
yeah it's very embarrassing having
feelings
i feel sad for you i love my desk buddy
sometimes detective kearns and i leave
presents for each other
yeah well lohank's a stubble monkey i
hate him anna's face garbage
why don't you just tell him to stop
shaving at his desk he denies even doing
it i don't know why
next time i catch him shaving i'm going
to punch him so hard and the mountain
bites his own heart
all right thank you for that shockingly
dark update anything else
uh yes something i'd like to say a
pretty private person so
this is kind of hard for me but here we
go
i'm bisexual all right i will now field
one minute and zero seconds of questions
pertaining to this go
amy how long have you known since
seventh grade i was watching save by the
bell and i thought zack morris is hot
and then i thought lisa turtle also hot
the fact that the words kelly and
kapowski didn't just come out of your
mouth is lunacy what made you decide to
tell us now charles found out on the
road trip and
i was positive he was not going to be
able to keep the secret for much longer
bye rosa i mean not
bye but bye i mean see ya i mean have
fun
only having sex with men just banging
dudes left and right i just stopped
saying bye all together so are you
seeing anyone now yeah her name's
tiffany are you lying about her name so
we won't look her up yes i am next
do you know anne haiti i do oh i must
say this is going considerably better
than when i came out to my colleagues
they were not as the kids say awake do
you mean woke i did mean woke but it's
grammatically incoherent
okay we have time for one more question
nope absolutely not we're done
smart it was not tasteful so
how did you two finally get together
after all these years oh
uh you know i'd just been crazy about
her forever and then one day i picked up
my battered old guitar and i
sang her a song oh how did it go
oh you don't want to hear it yes i do
well i don't have my guitar here sing
the song rosa rosa rosa rosa rosa
rosa rosa diaz diaz diaz diaz diaz diaz
diaz rosa diaz rosa diaz diaz rosariza
diaz diaz you are so cool
sounds better with a guitar
[Applause]
just put that away who was that in the
picture just my mom kind of looked like
your co-worker amy jake you can name
your friends
it's not weird he had his arm around her
and she was showing off a ring wow you
got a really good look at that picture
huh
what's going on
jake and him are engaged
that's okay what you understand love is
complicated
why would you be okay with that when you
call this dinner
you were so nervous we were worried you
were gonna tell us you were gay
so you would rather me be some dude's
mistress than be in a loving
relationship with a woman
well jake and i aren't dating but guess
what
your worst fears are real i'm not
straight i'm bisexual
and i don't care what you think about it
screw this i'm out of here
good what's this red area here the diaz
drangle right
so you know about rose's anger incidents
it's my birthday
i hate birthdays if you wish me a happy
birthday i will
punch you you're a funny little bird
diaz happy birthday
anytime mount diaz erupts everyone in
the squad avoids her
mountain is humorous yes tell me what
room is just down the hall from her desk
the bathroom if people are afraid to
walk by diaz
bathroom breaks will be to a minimum
hey diaz i just need to make sure i've
got the details right in this file
yeah guy was passing bad checks but is
this the same guy
yeah the name here is the same name
okay all right thank you thank you got
it
come on i'm so sick of these sucky
computers
[Music]
one more step in your next what were you
thinking
i made a mistake the phones were just
lying there and i didn't think things
through
i'm sorry rosa rosa is your friend from
before you were a criminal you are
dealing with detective diaz now and she
is gonna make sure you rot in juvie for
the rest of your life
whoa whoa whoa can i talk to you for a
minute
[Music]
hey i've been looking for you before you
decide what to do with sam
there's someone i think you should talk
[Music]
to
miriam surprise i tracked down your old
ballet coach
i brought iran to remind you of the
effect a kind nurturing presence
can have on a young life hello dear
have you continued to dance no miss
miriam well there's no surprise in that
you always were a lazy ox
what's this now look at your posture you
look as if you should be ringing the
bells at notre dame
miss miriam was not nurturing at all all
right ox
let's see what you've got five six seven
eight
eyes up shoulders down
well that wasn't terrible see serge
tough love works
damn it oh nothing better after a long
shift than coming to shaw's
it's like cheers where everybody knows
your name place where everybody knows
your name is hell you're describing
health
guys guys guys are those firefighters
okay here are the rules of the contest
if you order a drink
it must be fully consumed before you
order another each team's tab will be
tracked on that board
we don't want anyone getting alcohol
poisoning so if you throw up you're
disqualified
i never throw up i just told my stomach
to deal with it my body is terrified of
me
so what'd you think of ropesburg
it's a quaint it's
whack and you know it their number one
crime is tricycle theft
there's a bakery attached to the
precinct come on santiago
you never would have taken that job so
why'd you even care that they offered it
to me
i can't help it i'm competitive i have
seven brothers and i was the only girl i
always had to fight for a place at the
table well you're not the only girl at
the table anymore
we work in a police force full of dudes
we gotta have each other's backs okay
you saying you have my back yeah i got
your back don't smile i'm still mad at
you
i thought we were having a moment
moment's over shut up
you